sur ces images diffusées ce lundi matin
par l'armée russe
déblindés chasseurs et bombardiers
lancent leurs attaques sur l'Ukraine le
message est clair la Russie compte bien
resserrer son étreinte sur son voisin en
y multipliant les
frappes conséquence à Kiev les habitants
trouvent refuge dans les couloirs du
métro au cours de la nuit des drones et
des missiles russes sont ciblés
plusieurs villes et régions sur une
large partie du territoire ukrainien
annonce ce matin la
présidence l'enemi a tiré des dizaines
de missiles sur des villes et villages
il y a de nombreuses coupures
d'électricité et des immeubles
d'habitation endommagés la situation est
compliquée bilan plusieurs morts et des
dizaines de blessés l'un d'entre eux est
évacué des ruines ici à
carquif au sud à zaporidia ce quartier
résidentiel émerge d'une nuit d'angoisse
ses habitants constate les
dégâts on m'a prévenu cette nuit qu'il
allait y avoir un raid aérien mes
prochain et mois vont donc couru vers
l'abri plus tard un appel nous a appris
ce qui éta arrivé au bâtiment côté russe
les autorités annoncent ce lundi
l'évacuation d'environ 300 personnes de
Belgorod ces derniers jours les
bombardements Ukrainiens s'y
intensifient au cours des dernières 24
heures nous avons reçu 1300 demandes
visant à envoyer les enfants de Belgorod
dans des camps scolaires loin de la
ville dans d'autres
régions inédite en Russie la mesure met
à mal le discours du kremelin qui ni les
conséquences du conflit sur le quotidien
et la sécurité des
Russes le 30 décembre dernier 25 civils
avaient trouvé la mort lors d'une
attaque sur
Belgorod